we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i got a
voicemail from a nineteen year old with
a golden voice
truly a voice for radio with a question
he wants some advice from me take a
listen to this hey David so I'm a 19
year old college student my name's
Spencer so people say have a good radio
voice and I've also you know really
liked Clark politics and I sort of share
my views with people but I'd like some
advice so I can don't worry that my
ideas are not original or that you know
if I start like a blog or something that
they wouldn't take off or you know that
people will laugh like what I have to
say or like what my ideas are about like
the current situation I was kind of
wondering like did you have like same
concerns when you started the show and
you know like what made you want to
start the David Pakman show and like
what hurdles did you have to overcome
and you know what every other advice you
would have for me yeah listen here's the
thing your voice sounds great I don't
really think it matters that much I
think most people unless you have like
really a vocal issue where your voice is
is a problematic in some way and this
does exist you don't have it most of the
voice stuff can kind of be learned you
just get comfortable talking into a
microphone here's the thing you're gonna
have to get over quick if you want to do
anything in political media the idea
that people might laugh at disagree with
or criticize what you're doing or they
might call it trash they might call it
worthless they will call you worthless
at some point you're gonna have to get
over that and that's the biggest thing I
had to get over if you listen to like
the first three months of this show back
from 2009 in creditor 2005 I'm sorry you
will notice that I was playing it down
the middle a lot and it's very boring
and it's stupid and I barely knew how to
talk into a microphone I just had to get
over the fact that me doing a show where
I pretend to be you know just seeing
both sides of every issue it's boring
for me it's boring for the audience and
I just had to bite the bullet and say
you know what I'm gonna do the stories
as I see them you get used to the
criticism you get used to in my case the
anti-semitic comments and if you want to
do it you're just going to
to get over that that's really the big
thing more than your voice or anything
like that feel free to get in touch if
you have more questions glad glad to
talk to you about it and talk you
through it if you want we've got a great
bonus show for you today I'll talk about
a Passover fiasco that took place over
the weekend and much more that's it for
today new show new bonus show tomorrow
bonus show right now for our members and
patrons